we all know that laughter is the best
medicine am i right cheryl absolutely
sandra bullock appeared on the kelly
clarkson show and as we know sometimes
the best interviews are the ones that
get completely out of hand um as the two
couldn't contain themselves during an
uncontrollable lap fest i know and when
they laugh you can't help but laugh uh
and these two are just really funny
together so sandra joked that kelly
accidentally called her a [ __ ] and we
all love a good blooper so cheryl we
found this take a look at the mo at this
moment of you from 2018.
[Music]
wedding fever is at an all-time ho
it's awful
that's awful that is awful
not at a wedding either
you're so beautiful like you were so
like regal looking and you're like oh
and you played it off so well so it just
was like whoop
yeah no you just played it off so well
david was saying so it was very very
good love that i say we move on now over
to sandra and kelly take a look at this
the um your kids have a talent for
singing they love singing my daughter
does okay she has some pipes that's
exactly it's so you know they say it
skips a gym my parents were i was gonna
say your parents i cannot sing at all my
parents were singing about that um it's
okay but they were singers though okay
but that's cool wait you don't see that
they're dead or no they're singers
that's so sad that they're
sweating
oh my god this is the worst date ever
okay so wait no no
no
that's so sad oh my god
wiki
[Laughter]
[Applause]
honestly god
like it's uncanny how close to like my
friends you are
the things that you've got like your
friends are horses as well
oh my friends are horses
oh i'm sure you're not like i'm fine i
know you're fine everything's fine i've
got makeup on my nails oh i love makeup
so wait here's the thing
it's okay okay
this is your favorite interview i'm
aware
so wait since we bought in here it's hot
that's what i said i'm sweating okay
fine no one else is sweating do you
actually decorate for christmas i do i
do i do i
that's
you figured me out